right along and speaking apart in my
take you had a guest this week who's
been on everything except this show
Julian Edelman making the rounds in
support of a documentary that debuts
tonight on Showtime and one of the
issues that came up and I I'm sorry I
haven't listened to the Edelman
interview on part of my take yet but one
of the things that's bothered Chris Sims
and me he's got a four game suspension
for PE D use he's never really explained
what happened
you know usually we get the well I got a
supplement that was tainted we haven't
even gotten that for it from him now
maybe you did or maybe somebody else did
I haven't seen it written I haven't
heard anything about it but I it you
know
P D suspension isn't a marijuana
suspension it means you took something
that is deemed to be extra and above
what you should be taking it falls into
the category of cheating and I feel like
he's just skated on this one yes he
missed the four games but he's never had
to discuss it I don't think he's gotten
asked many questions about it it's
almost like it never even happened but
for the fact that he missed four games
well it helps that you blue and you play
for the Patriots you don't have to talk
to the media very often and you can kind
of skirt these questions by basically
doing the patriot way we did talk to him
we danced around it we talked about how
his father didn't talk to him for a few
months afterwards and I think that you
know if you kind of deduce how we spoke
about it the pressure he felt knowing
that Bill Belichick will cut a guy even
if he is one of them a couple Super
Bowls I think he almost alluded to the
fact that maybe he did do something that
was trying to get an edge trying to get
his rehab back I also think Mike to
speak honestly i the the peds in the
rehab always are treated a little
differently than peds just peds right I
think maybe should they be I I'm not I'm
not here to judge whether it should or
should not be that way and I get your
point that it probably should be brought
up you're gonna judge everything it's no
to judge it come on man take a stand no
no no what I'm saying is I'm stating a
fact that it is treated differently I'm
not telling you whether that's right or
I get it's not treated differently but I
have I have less of a problem with guys
doing peds to come back for me
so there's my stand I do I do that's
just a fact over me I personally if a
guy gets injured playing a really
violent sport and it's really hard to
come back from injury and Iceman up
exactly that pressure knowing that the
NFL will cut you and you will be out and
there's not guaranteed contracts I have
less of a problem with a guy doing peds
when he's coming back from injury versus
a guy who's doing Peavey's to just get
an edge when he's already healthy so
there it is there's an edge I know but
an edge is an edge and until the NFLPA
sit down and negotiate an exception and
and look there's been Kurt Warner has
gotten on board with it this week Sims
has advocated the idea of a very limited
window of injuries and a limited window
of peds that could be used to help you
recover but that would take them off the
banned list as it stands if it's on the
list and you take it you're done and the
NFL and the Union have yet to
acknowledge that there is an exception
for guys coming back from injury maybe
there should be until there is though
you're no different than the guy who's
saying man if I was just a little bit
faster if I was a little bit stronger
maybe I'd be a starter instead of a
backup it's still cheating because it's
an ultimate competition and whatever
Julian Edelman did to put himself back
on the field that took away someone
else's chance to perform and to thrive
because Edelman adamant cut corners to
ensure that he'd be ready to go you're
misunderstanding what I'm saying I'm not
saying it's not cheating I'm not saying
that Julian Edelman was was right or
saying he didn't deserve a suspension
what I'm saying is your original
question why isn't he being asked this
more often why isn't it being brought up
more often I personally don't think it
is as big of a deal if you do peds to
come back for injury and I think it is
treated differently by the media by
Twitter by fans and you will not get the
same questions that you would have
gotten if you got busted for peds in the
middle of a healthy season that's just
the reality of it that's where I'm
coming I'm trying to answer the question
of why he hasn't been asked it more
often and that's that's honestly how I
feel
62% of the people who responded to a
poll question we had on Twitter this
week agree with you 38% say there is no
difference 62% say there
is a difference ultimately there isn't a
difference in my assessment I can
understand why someone would be tempted
to do it and maybe the deeper
conversation here is the pressure that
is put on guys to come back and play
because if you don't you will lose your
job Bill Belichick will dump you and you
and and so it's not a difficult thing in
the analysis okay hmm
I can get myself ready to go and I'm
playing a mini game of Russian roulette
here that I'm gonna get caught in I'll
miss four games but you know what I'll
be ready to go for the other twelve
games and maybe I'll be ready to go for
the postseason and maybe we'll win the
Superbowl and maybe I'll be the MVP
it's an easy it's as justification goes
it's an easy bridge to cross to say I'm
gonna go ahead and take that PE D
absolutely and my question to you is do
you think guaranteeing money
guaranteeing contracts insuring
contracts against injury do you think
that changes the dynamics a little bit
because you know if you're talking about
baseball or basketball or even hockey
when you get injured you know that that
money that you signed for is still
coming in you know that you're gonna
still be paid that money when you get
injured in football it's very hard to
come back the average you know a
lifespan of a football career is what
two and a half years or whatever it may
be injuries are very difficult when you
have a league that's getting younger and
younger and the way everything is
structured teams want to get younger and
pay guys less do you think there's an
element of if they figured out a way to
guarantee these contracts guys would
have wood wood with the the calculations
would be a little different the risk
would not be you know you wouldn't want
to take that risk on your career on your
reputation if you knew you were gonna
get paid no matter what that's a good
point I have two points to make a
response first of all if there were
guaranteed contracts the contracts
generally will be shorter and it's
entirely possible that when Julian
Elementor is ACL he would have been in
the last year of his contract so there
would have been no protection anyway
that and for any player out there that's
clamoring for guaranteed contracts
you're not going to get a six year fully
guaranteed contract you're gonna get
three at the absolute most most
contracts will be one year at that point
and you'll have the freedom to move but
you're not going to have that that
security that protects you against a
serious injury into the neck
year second point is this Edelman did
have a contract that covered him into
2018 and under the current CBA there
isn't allowance there that you can make
a large percentage of your money if the
injury that affected you the one year
carries into the next year that still
isn't the that's not much of a
consolation because you just want to
play right and you're still making less
money than you would have made but there
is some protection that's currently
baked in but not enough but if it was a
truly guaranteed contract Bill Belichick
may not be handing out more than a
two-year contract to anyone in Edelman
may not have had that protection in any
event okay I'm not a cap ologist and I
don't really claim to understand the ins
and outs of the financial part of the
game but let me just throw this out
there what if there is a salary cap what
if there are guaranteed contracts but if
a guy gets injured and you cut them it
doesn't count against your salary cap
anymore so you have the ability to pay
guys for four or five years because
guess what we know the NFL is making a
ton of money we know these owners are
making a ton of money the willingness to
pay them I think would be less about the
money and more about you don't want to
hamper yourself for four years out when
a guy could get injured or end up being
bad and you can't get any relief from
your salary cap and you can't go pay
someone younger who's better so if you
guaranteed the contracts but you had
that in there where if a guy gets hurt
or if you want to cut a guy just
outright you still have to pay him but
it doesn't count against your salary cap
I don't know this is probably a million
ways that doesn't work but I'm just
throwing it out there yeah and and
here's the thing it operates under a
premise that the teams are restraining
themselves from overspending and they're
all pressed up against the top of the
cap one of the dirty little secrets are
down the NFL there are plenty of teams
that are hoarding cap space because they
are hoarding dollars you only have to
spend eighty nine cents of every dollar
under the salary cap I mean the
presumption is that oh I'd spend more if
I could well not every team most teams
are spending less and they're carrying
that cap space so it's not about the
money it's about having a healthy body
on the field and I think that's what
element oh he wanted to apply I mean
yeah the money's fine it's not like he's
making huge money it's about wanting to
play and I think that's the thing that
motivates a guy to take the PE D to get
himself back where he can play where he
can compete cuz autumn
he got the payoff he has the Super Bowl
MVP trophy and the fame and the
documentary and the media tour that goes
along with it if he doesn't take that PE
D last year to speed his recovery from
the ACL tear there's a damn good chance
we're not talking about Julian Edelman
right now there's a damn good chance
there's no documentary coming out
tonight there's a damn good chance you
don't want him on PMT this week and the
Colbert doesn't want him on late night
and all everybody else that had him
doesn't want him because he didn't win
the MVP because he wasn't able to go so
as overall you know bargains and
rationalizations and deals with the
devil go is a pretty good deal it paid
off for Julian Edelman so what about the
the other thing you could do is if you
were very much against this type of you
know getting back from injury taking
peds or just make the suspension longer
right it's clear that the risk like you
just said the calculation that Julian
Edelman did said hey if I can get an
edge to get back on the field all I got
to do is sit for game sitting September
is not that big of a deal when you're
talking about a 16-game season that's
punishing and then an extra three games
or four games in January and February so
like baseball I think baseball is what
50 games to start and then it keeps
going up from there so that's a third of
the season so if you made it you know
six games or eight games then now the
calculation feels a little different now
it says hey do I really want to take
this if I'm gonna miss half of a season
because of a busted test well and beyond
that being knocked out of the postseason
like baseball does you serve your
suspension and you can't participate in
the postseason and we put that out on
Twitter also 60 percent said no they
don't want the four-game suspension and
a banned from post-season play but
already the NFL they won't let you're
playing the Pro Bowl if you had a PE D
violation but they will let your play in
the Super Bowl
so they've at least entertained the idea
that something's not right with this
picture and we need to do something
about it but they haven't gone far
enough and maybe one of the reasons why
we don't care as much as we should as
fans and his media about these issues
the penalty isn't as strong as it could
be or should be so if we look at the NFL
and we think the NFL doesn't really care
why should we and and I think that
contributes to this sense of of apathy
when a guy like Julian Edelman gets a PD
violation and we
oh yeah he just had a torn ACL he's
doing what he has to do to come back
yeah
it's an interesting discussion I mean I
don't really know I told you my honest
opinion that they're coming back from
injury does feel a little different and
whether that's right or wrong I you know
you can tell me I'm wrong and that makes
no sense that's fine I'm just telling
you that it feels different what he's
coming back from injury but the whole
thing is an interesting discussion and I
don't know can we get a league where
everyone can just do whatever they want
it's it's it's out there people talk
about you know maybe making a league
where it's just everyone everyone does
whatever they want
and and we'll see how it goes I don't
think that would be the safest but
there's probably fans out there that
would want it there's fans out there
they're wanted and there were players
that would line up out the door to play
for it old school football hit like they
did in the eighties take whatever you
have to take do whatever you want like
like a real-life version of NFL Blitz
remember that game that it would be
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports